is the biggest park in the middle of
Berlin and a place with many faces
during the day you see here a lot of
people tourists for example who want to
discover the city from this park as
there are a lot of historic sites nearby
but as it gets dark there is a different
crowd gathering young refugees willing
to sell their bodies and we don't have
to look for long to find them young men
who gather here at dusk none of them
want to talk on camera they fear it
might jeopardize their Asylum process
like farad 21 from Afghanistan no homo
sapien
drugs forced me to do this job I have to
earn money for drugs wonderful require a
look Wow
he doesn't want to talk about the job in
detail some clients pay as little as 5
euros most of the refugees are ashamed
how do you try to make some money they
don't tell anyone especially not their
families back at home why they face so
many risks
social workers know their stories and
try to help Diana says hundreds of them
sells sex during the night to buy drugs
during the day someone arriving here
from a war zone has probably seen people
die along the way companies he confronts
all this German bureaucracy and he comes
to find out he would have to wait for
years to be considered for asylum and
during that long wait he encounters
people who don't want him here he starts
to get depressed and turns to drugs is
in that room
then he Civic yeah drugs numb their
feelings of hopelessness some asked
local aid groups for clothes but that's
not nearly enough to help them turn
their lives around look the most
important thing is to engage with them
and the care to do that is language if
these people from countries like Iraq
Afghanistan Iran are denied integration
classes while they're waiting for their
asylum statuses to be approved they are
lost for one back in the park dozens of
young men are getting ready to make
money again so is farad telecoil with
kikuna my expectation when I came to
Germany was that my family and I would
have a good life
I left a bad life in Afghanistan
in order to study here to learn a
language to have a better life but I
don't big you know then the humic object
and neither he still hopes things may
turn out well once he receives his
asylum status and documents to learn
German and apply for a job but that can
take four years